without Mary Austin it's hard to say
where Freddie Mercury and by extension
Queen would have ended up Austin was a
lover confidant and friend to the
legendary rock star and helped mercury
reach the heights of superstardom
British American actress Lucy Boynton
played Austin on the big screen in
Bohemian Rhapsody and she sure looked
familiar here are a few roles who may
have seen Boynton and before her big
break through even though Bohemian
Rhapsody gave Boyden a chance to show
off her dramatic acting chops she's made
a name for herself in horror movie
circles one of her most recent features
apostle is a bloody period piece that
fits squarely in that category apostle
tells the story of a man in 1905 trying
to rescue his kidnapped sister from a
dangerous religious cult on a remote
island as supplies on the island run low
when the faithful begin to lose hope the
group's leader prophet Malcolm begins to
take more desperate and drastic measures
Boynton plays prophet Malcolm's daughter
Andrea who is beginning to understand
the evil that her father is capable of
Bohemian Rhapsody was not Boynton's
first turn in a star-studded major
motion picture just a year before the
oscar-nominated biopic the actress was
cast as countess Elena in director
Kenneth Branagh retelling of the Agatha
Christie classic Murder on the Orient
Express the timid countess hides a
shadowy past and continually takes drugs
to help her sleep during the day as such
Boynton described the character to
Vanity Fair as being easily confused
because she's frequently unsure whether
it's day or night to help convey that
sense the actress tried to express quote
a feeling of a slightly damaged
butterfly in an interview with W
Magazine Boynton said that she would
like to play a wide variety of
characters in her career but darker
roles appealed to her more that would
certainly apply to her role in the
Netflix series [ __ ] Boynton plays
Alison Adams a pill addict to his
seeking treatment from a therapist
played by Naomi Watts a woman with her
own set of issues as Alison gets deeper
into her treatment gene struggles to
stay within the typical boundaries that
exist between a counselor and her
patient Boyton talked to Entertainment
Weekly about the experience of making
the show saying she was drawn to the
dark project because the writing allows
viewers to see quote the truest dirtiest
sides of people
speaking of dark projects director Polly
Steel's letmego was crowdfunded and
based on the autobiographical book of
the same name by Helga Schneider about
learning that her estranged mother had
been a guard at a Nazi concentration
camp the film tells the story from the
perspective of Helga who at age 60
receives a letter detailing her aging
mother's whereabouts along with her
daughter Beth and granddaughter Emily
played by Boynton Helga travels to
Vienna to see her mother one last time
where she finds the matriarch
remorseless about her role in the
Holocaust Catcher in the Rye author JD
Salinger was a notorious recluse until
his death in 2010 and refused to allow a
film adaptation of his novel to be made
saying it was quote unactive or director
Danny strong attempted the next best
thing with rebel and the RAI which
chronicles the life of Salinger as he
wrote the landmark novel Nicholas how to
plays a young Salinger who along the way
meets Clare Douglas played by Boynton in
real life Douglass was the inspiration
for Franny glass the character featured
in Salinger's Franny and Zooey poorer
films were a hallmark of Lucy Boynton's
early career don't knock twice like
letmego is a story about mothers and
daughters except with way more ghosts
Boynton plays Chloe a teenager who
unwittingly awakens a witch living in an
abandoned house in an effort to escape
the evil Chloe flees to the country to
stay with her estranged mother Jess Jess
is a successful artist who lives with
her lawyer husband and now wants to
reconnect with her daughter after
previously losing her to foster care
because of a substance abuse problem but
the witch problem they're all facing now
may prove worse I am the pretty thing
that lives in the house was the second
collaboration between Boynton and
director Osgood Oz Perkins the son of
psycho star Anthony Perkins much like
his father's most famous flick the movie
centers on a dwelling where creepy
things happen in this case it's the 200
year old New England home of iris Blum a
popular author of horror novels things
get weird when Miss Blum's new nurse
Lily realizes that the old woman is
talking to someone named Polly who
doesn't appear to be there or is she
point in place Polly the main character
of the lady in the wall one of Blum's
novels from decades ago but it's
possible that Polly is more than just a
fictional character
and flashbacks Polly is seen as a young
woman condemned to a terrible fate Singh
Street was Boynton's first lead acting
role having been previously relegated to
supporting characters the musical story
about a teenager in Dublin trying to
start a band in order to impress a girl
was popular at Sundance when it
premiered in 2016 and was nominated for
Golden Globe for Best Picture Musical or
Comedy never do anything by half
Boynton plays Rufina an aspiring model
being wooed by fourteen-year-old Conor
Cosmo la loire for Boyton the film was a
new experience it was one of the few
times in her young career that she was
one of the oldest actors on set in 2015
Boynton teamed up with director oz
Perkins for the first time in the black
coats daughter a film that was
originally called February when it made
its premiere at the Toronto Film
Festival after being held in release
date limbo for more than a year the
movie hit streaming services with a new
title in the movie Cats
played by Keanu Shipka and Rose played
by Boynton are stuck at a Catholic girls
boarding school when a mysterious young
woman arrives before too long captain
Rose are left to battle and unforeseen
evil copperhead is a period drama that
was only boynton second film credits in
the movie
Boynton plays ester Hagedorn daughter of
a hardline upstate New York abolitionist
during the Civil War
ester falls in love with Jeff beech the
son of a pacifist the vast political
difference between the lovers fathers
threatens to derail their relationship
the movie was based on the book the
Copperhead by Harold Frederick which
examined the differing political
attitudes that existed on the homefront
during America's Civil War Boynton made
her big screen debut in miss Potter at
the age of eleven she was cast as a
young Beatrix Potter the famed author
who created the Tale of Peter Rabbit and
a number of other classic children's
books with charming animal characters it
didn't take long for young Lucy to be
bitten by the acting bug
she told WWD that on her first day on
the set of miss Potter she decided that
nothing else quote could make her as
happy or feel as fulfilled as acting
does so they say check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite actors
are coming soon so
scribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you